[Music]
james is in philadelphia hi james how
are you
hi dave how you doing today good how can
we help
good um i just had a quick question so
um
my wife is in 139 000
of student loan debt um we recently just
purchased
a home about two months ago
um really the only debt that we have
is the house and her student loans we
have no car payments
um no credit card debt nothing like that
i just want to know the best way to
tackle her student loan bet should you
know whether
we should just like pay half of it and
then refinance it or just save up for
the whole thing and
i just want to know the best way to
tackle it how much do you guys make
james a year um so my
my wife makes about 42 uh
42 000 a year um i am a loan officer
i've worked these basically commissioned
but my year to date should be about like
260 000
uh this year why did she go 140 000
in debt making forty thousand dollars a
year what is she doing
um so she went to a private institution
um she was originally gone for um
like fashion merchandising marketing um
very niche market uh
to really break into um so it's pretty
hard to find
a job um but yeah so here's what i would
do
um if you make three hundred thousand
dollars a year and you have a hundred
thirty thousand dollars in debt i would
pay off your debt in one year
okay 140 140 from 300 leaves you plenty
to live on
okay like we have we have about like
sixty six thousand sixty six thousand in
the bank now
good right that write that check against
it and then you're paid off in six
months
okay you're not gonna do any of this are
you
no no i am it's just it's it's hard to
let go of the money
like yeah i mean that would that would
be draining the bank account like that
would be complete dude
you have to get rid of this sally mae is
an ugly old woman and she's in your
house and she won't leave until you
throw her out
and the faster you throw her out the
faster you're gonna get on with your
life
let me tell you the problem with paying
off your student loan debt you're not
gonna do it
that's the problem you're gonna have to
get on this
like it matters and if you don't it's
gonna hang around for another 10 years
and you'll have a bunch of theories
and still have sally mae in your bedroom
this is the dave ramsey show